papa
[Musique]
et
gardé par les cadets de l'armée sous
couvert d'un temps de les tops brodés
qui couvre traditionnellement la kaaba
de la mecque
le cercueil du souverain a été exposée
sur la place du mechouar en présence de
ses deux fils hassan de son successeur
et moulay abdallah entourant le
président bourguiba et des délégués de
nombreuses nations parmi lesquels
monsieur geoffroy de courcel
représentant le général de gaulle il
devait être ensuite placé sur une
prolonge d'artillerie pour être conduit
à sa dernière demeure
[Musique]
sur le parcours près d'un million de
personnes peut-être mêlant les larmes
aux gémissements les clameurs aux
invocations se pressait le long de ce
cortège immense que précéder les fils du
roi défunt
le président tunisien est le chef du
gouvernement sénégalais monsieur mamadou
dia
foule exaltée au milieu de laquelle
s'abat parfois une forme humaine
au comble de l'émotion
trajet coupé par une pause à la mosquée
de yacoub el mansour dans les ruines
dominera da ou au milieu des colonne
brisée
le roi était venu faire sa première
prière à son retour d'exil
c'est dans l'enceinte du palais que
reposera le roi mohamed 5 dans le décor
traditionnel camp tour aujourd'hui un
maroc nouveau où les surprises ne sont
pas exclues
puisque la cavalerie moderne a remplacé
les chevaux d'autrefois par des motos on
ne s'étonnera pas que le motocross et
quelques rapports avec le jumping
c'est ainsi qu'au deuxième moto cross
international de barcelone qui
réunissait quelques uns des champions de
la spécialité
on a enregistré une succession de sauts
très réussie qu'on mange
c'est un véritable sport que se livrent
chaque soir les banlieusards de tokyo et
quel sport il s'agit pour plus de 3
millions de travailleurs de trouver une
place dans l'un des wagons du métro pour
nom d'un fn y parvient
et ceux qui parviennent à monter ne
peuvent pas se vanter de le faire sans
dommage si bien que le métro de tokyo
est en mesure d'ouvrir un marché de
chaussures et de boutons d'occasions
[Musique]
c'était autre chose n'a pas été sans
attirer l'attention des autorités
compétentes qui ont organisé une série
de conférences destiné à éduquer le
public
d'autre part pour mettre un peu d'ordre
dans ce désordre
on a établi une série de barrages propre
à fractionner le flux des usagers
enfin on a créé une brigade spéciale
qu'on pourrait appeler brigade de
compression
[Musique]
les employés qui en font partie sont
proposés aux différentes portières ou
leur mission est de faire entrer à
l'intérieur tous qui débat
à
solution logique sans doute énergique
sans conteste mais qui n'a qu'un
lointain rapport avec l'idée que l'on
peut se faire des commodités du progrès
m
dans la salle du trône du palais de ryad
à rabat le jeune roi hassan 2 porté à la
souveraineté par la mort de son père
mohamed 5 adressé à la nation son
premier message dans lequel il s'affirme
le continuateur de la politique de son
prédécesseur
[Musique]
il devait ensuite selon le protocole
traditionnel
vêtu de la djellaba blanche et dans un
carrosse tiré par six chevaux se rendre
à la mosquée pour y présider la prière
du vendredi
ce geste traditionnel qu'ils
accomplissaient pour la première fois en
qualité d'iman des croyants a suscité
parmi la foule
un grand mouvement de ferveur qui
semblent plébisciter le début du nouveau
reine
[Musique]
e
on sait qu'à la suite des funérailles de
mohamed 5
le président bourguiba avait rencontré
au palais de rabat monsieur ferhat abbas
le jeune roi du maroc avait rejoint ces
deux personnalités pour participer à
leur conversation sur le problème
algérien
cette réunion s'est terminée par un
communiqué mentionnant qu'il n'existe
aucun obstacle à l'ouverture de
négociations directes entre le gpr à et
la france
les arts ménagers ont déménagé c'est au
palais de la défense qu'ils se sont
installés dans notre époque de progrès
il va de soi qu'il s'adresse autant qu'à
la ménagère au chef de famille qui ne
saurait manquer d'y suivre son épouse la
découverte des mille et un ustensile de
fer par un libre service aux convoitises
des femmes pratiquent ne peut que lui
être agréable
il n'est pas non plus sans importance
qu'ils puissent tout savoir du maniement
du moderne tampon miracle qui nettoie
tout puisque somme toute il y a quelques
chances pour qu'ils le retrouvent à la
maison
il est également du plus haut intérêt
qu'ils sachent que les chaussures ne se
sert pas tout seul et que les produits
de première qualité ne seraient opérés
par enchantement le petit miracle
quotidien
[Musique]
e
le convient-il pas aussi qu'il n'ignore
rien de ces papier chiffon qui se jette
après usage et qui peuvent si bien
essuyer la vaisselle
que de choses un époux digne de ce nom
n'a t-il pas à apprendre aux arts
ménagers et n'est-il pas juste qu'il
soit à même de juger par lui-même du
poids de toutes les connaissances que
requiert la tenue d'un ménage le
répétons le messieurs une visite aux
arts ménagers ne peut que vous être
profitable vous y découvrirez d'ailleurs
la maison de vos rêves avec l'intérieur
de vos rêves et les fauteuils de vos
rêves
mais n'est-ce pas navrant de voir le peu
d'empressement que mettre les en as
instruits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous nous improvisé acrobates d'un soir
dont eur inattendu se sont succédé dans
le cercle enchanté du cirque d'hiver
pour la 31e fois le gala de l'union des
artistes mettait en piste ceux et celles
qui d'habitude sont plutôt les autres de
la scène et de l'écran et un public de
choix celui qu'on nomme le tout-paris
applaudi une nouvelle écuyère brigitte
aubert
[Musique]
le numéro de trapèze de jean pierre
cassel et françoise dorléac a pu faire
passer un frisson jean cocteau qui par
la cie parfaitement du cirque et jean
marais qui fut dresseur et acrobates
dans de précédents galas de l'union les
ont applaudis en connaisseur
marie dance a étonné tout le monde en
jouant les femmes serpent en compagnie
de quelques virtuoses de l'équilibré
[Musique]
et
quant à joséphine baker plus belle que
jamais elle a conduit avec une maestria
étonnante d'aller d'éléphant tout cela
pour venir en aide aux artistes dans la
nécessité et pour montrer que le bon
coeur peut faire très bon ménage avec le
courage et le talent
c'est dans une atmosphère digne des
légendes orientales que s'est terminé le
voyage de la reine elizabeth dans ce qui
fut l' empire des indes
à bénarès elle devait être l'hôte du
maharadjah de la cité sainte qui
déployait en son honneur le faste le
plus fantastique 14 éléphants au
palanquin d'or et d'argent massifs ont
ramené la reine et son cortège jusqu'au
gange le fleuve sacré dont les eaux
enlève les péchés
au milieu des fidèles qui se plongent
dans ces eaux purificatrice la reine
parcourra le fleuve le long du quai ne
se développe avec son pittoresque
étonnant la ville qui est pour 200
millions de fidèles à la foi la mecque
et jérusalem est qui est la ville la
plus étonnante peut-être de l'inde
entière
[Musique]